hola muchas gracias por estar aquí ya es
la última mi nombre es georgina
gutiérrez estudié la carrera de diseño
industrial pero hoy me dedico a pintar y
hoy muy orgullosa parada en este en este
escenario puedo decir que poco a poco me
he ido convirtiendo en artista
siempre me ha gustado pintar pero yo no
me quería dedicar a pintar yo no quería
ser artista para mí ser artista
significaba
que nadie me tomara en serio como un
trabajo de broma que alguien me fuera a
preguntar y que haces dibujitos yo no
quería pintar sentía que pintar podría
ser un hobby pero no mi carrera y fue
así como decidí estudiar diseño
industrial sentí que era una decisión
más madura responsable y entonces elegí
esa carrera y la verdad es que me
encantó me gustó mucho mi carrera el
problema empezó cuando la gente comenzó
a preguntarme ya qué te vas a dedicar en
que quieres trabajar qué vas a hacer por
el resto de tu vida y yo decía no tengo
ni idea me gusta mi carrera pero no me
gusta ningún trabajo que me ofrece la
vida laboral
y entonces comencé a preocuparme por
suerte mis amigas y yo leímos un libro
llamado el sari rojo' de javier moro
gracias a este libro nos inspiramos a
hacer un viaje a la india una última
gran aventura antes de convencer de
comenzar a vivir una vida en un trabajo
de ocho de la mañana a seis de la tarde
donde te dan seis días de vacaciones y
decíamos nadie nos va a volver a dar
vacaciones entonces antes de salir de la
cárcel después de salir de la carrera
hagamos un último viaje tres meses de
mochilazo en la india pero yo quería ser
muy responsable siempre y dije como le
voy a hacer para conseguir ese dinero
para viajar cuatro meses si no tengo
trabajo y entonces dije ok voy a
pintar un cuadro que me recuerde todos
los días
te los voy a enseñar pinte ese cuadro y
lo puse frente a mi cama para recordarme
todos los días que quería ir a la india
no sabía cómo pero quería ir a una amiga
mía le encantó el cuadro y me dijo me
encantó y la vi dije bueno te lo regalo
yo siempre me puedo pintar otro esta
amiga subió una foto a instagram y una
amiga suya le dijo y me encantó ese
cuadro yo quiero uno y así conseguí mi
primer cliente así me di cuenta que
podía vender cuadros para irme a la
india y así fue como durante un año
vendí aproximadamente 40 cuadros de
todos los estilos formas colores lo que
fuera que me pidieran eso pintaba
cuando pablo ruiz picasso tenía 19 años
se mudó de su natal madrid a parís para
realizar su primera exposición como
solista durante un mes él pintó más de
60 cuadros
inspirándose en artistas como goya
velázquez los impresionistas
en su exposición cuando entró la gente y
vio estos 60 cuadros pintados a la
perfección se maravillaron de este
pintor tan talentoso guau cómo pudo
haber reflejado el estilo de tantos
artistas
pero él no tenía una voz propia él ahí
no tenía un estilo y pablo ruiz picasso
no sólo quería ser un pintor talentoso
él quería volverse picasso
todos aprendemos copiando es verdad así
es como aprendemos a hablar vemos a
nuestros papás e invitamos sus sonidos
así es para todas las habilidades que
queremos aprender lo copiamos vemos qué
hacen las demás personas estudiamos sus
trayectorias sus historias esas personas
que admiramos y las seguimos y es verdad
que todos aprendemos copiando pero llegó
un momento en el que cuando aprendiste
la técnica cuando ya estudiaste lo
suficiente es necesario dejar de copiar
es necesario comenzar a crear dejar de
imitar seguir al propio corazón
porque los pintores son expertos para
copiar son muy buenos en realizar el
trabajo de alguien más pero los artistas
son los que se inspiran en el trabajo de
alguien más pero pueden crear algo
totalmente único
después de viajar a la india perdón
después de que llegue a la india después
de mis 40 cuadros lo logré ahí estaba y
llegué a una ciudad llamada ricci cage
donde por casualidades de la vida había
un festival de arte callejero en la
ciudad estaba llena de pintores y
artistas llenando las paredes de colores
llenando la ciudad de vida y en un acto
de valentía me acerqué a los
organizadores y les dije que si yo
también podía pintar
y me dieron una pared
les quiero enseñar la pareja esta fue mi
gran pared como pueden ver chance y la
ven y no es la pared más emocionante del
mundo en el costado de un restaurante y
realmente estaba en un sitio de taxis
donde realmente mi moral casi nunca se
veía porque siempre había coches
estacionados solo utilice tres colores
pues tenía que cargar las pinturas de
atravesar un puente colgado y caminar un
kilómetro para ir por más pinturas pero
nada de eso me importó
pinte mi moral y cuando estaba ahí
en ese momento
ahorita este fue este fue el resultado
y les voy a decir que sé que no es la
pared más impresionante o el mural más
impresionante que han visto pero cuando
estaba ahí cuando pinte me sentí
verdaderamente viva viva como hace mucho
no me había sentido sabía que quería
pintar ahí me di cuenta que pintar edad
lo que amaba que me encantaba estar ahí
que no importaba si tenía que pintar
desde las 6 de la mañana hasta las 6 de
la tarde sin comer sin nada me encantaba
ahí había encontrado eso que me hacía
sentir viva
después de su exposición
picasso
se sentía un poco triste pues no había
encontrado su estilo porque aunque su
exposición había sido un éxito nadie lo
había llamado artista después tuvo un
tiempo difícil porque uno de sus mejores
amigos se suicidó ese verano
picasso se sentía deprimido triste se
sentía azul
así que lo que hizo fue tomar todo ese
azul que sentía toda esa tristeza toda
esa miseria y la puso en un cuadro
y por primera vez pintó con su estilo y
con su voz porque puso todo eso que
había en su corazón y lo puso ahí y así
es como ahora conocemos la época azul de
picasso los primeros cuadros cuadros por
los cuales fueron fue reconocido
el estilo de un artista es sumamente
valioso
el estilo de un artista es lo que lo
hace único en el estilo es por lo que
conocemos los cuadros de alguien es esa
cualidad que muchos artistas buscan pero
muy pocos se encuentran porque la
mayoría lo busca fuera en las opiniones
de los demás en las tendencias en la
sociedad en que lo gustar a los otros
pero el estilo de un artista se
encuentra dentro el estilo de la artista
ni siquiera lo tienes que ir a buscar
pues ya naciste con él eres tú este
auténtico ser
pero pintar con estilo y con el estilo
propio requiere coraje porque eso
significa que vas a dejar que te vean
tal cual eres porque cuando pintas con
tu estilo le dices al mundo este soy yo
y este es mi mensaje
cuando estaba en este mural cuando lo
termine me sentía viva pero no bastaron
unas horas para que empezaran a llegar
los miedos geo cómo vas a vivir de
pintar y si a nadie le gusta lo que
haces pintaste dos elefantitos por favor
te van a contratar para pintar cuartos
de bebés nunca van a estar tus cuadros
en un museo nunca vas a lograr grandes
cosas y comencé a sentir miedo miedo
miedo miedo y fue demasiado y volví a
silenciar mi voz y volví a decir eso es
verdad
no voy a hacer artista si descubrí que
me gusta pintar pero lo voy a hacer en
mis ratos libres no va a ser artista así
que regresé a méxico y me busque uno de
esos trabajos que yo decía este si el
super responsable es una empresa muy
reconocida esto es lo que hacen los
adultos trabajar de 8 a 6 eso es lo que
voy a hacer
fui super infeliz
me acuerdo qué
estaba un día comiendo en mi coche
porque comía en mi coche y estaba muy
triste
y ahorita les cuento la historia
era parís de 1847 74 perdón
era una época donde se los pintores más
talentosos eran los que pintaban de la
manera más real la técnica más valuada
era esa que parecía una fotografía y de
repente llegaron unos artistas locos y
vanguardistas y decidieron armar su
propia exposición pues nadie los quería
exponer y decidieron comenzar a pintar
cosas como esta
el sol saliente el sol de moneta
estos artistas fueron criticados los
críticos fueron implacables con ellos se
burlaron de ellos dijeron eso parece un
boceto eso parece que ni está terminado
que es eso son un chiste
de hecho escribió una reseña sobre ellos
en el periódico donde decía la impresión
que me dio que me dieron sus cuadros era
que realmente no estaban terminados y
los llamaron la exposición de los
impresionistas
hoy es el grupo de pintores los
impresionistas son
que les puedo decir cambio en el rumbo
de la historia del arte son esos
pintores los cuales decidieron justo no
hacer lo que todos esperaban que
hicieran decidieron utilizar su voz y
pintar algo totalmente único decidieron
que no les iba a importar la crítica que
les habían hecho y seguirían pintando y
pintando y pintando y gracias a que
siguieron pintando cambiaron el rumbo de
la historia del arte e inspiraron a
miles de artistas
puede que al mundo no le guste tu obra
puede que el mundo no quiera comprar lo
que haces hoy en día puede que lo
critiquen puede que se burlen de él
pero no importa pinta eso que tú quieres
sigue a tu corazón porque los artistas
no piden permiso a nadie para pintar los
artistas no se fijan en lo que quiere la
gente los artistas al único crítico que
le rinden cuentas es el de su corazón
los pintores
pueden copiar cualquier cuadro
pero tienen una vida más cómoda pues
nunca se arriesgan viven a la segura
viven cautelosamente nadie los critica
porque no hacen nada nuevo
ahora sí les voy a terminar de contar
estaba en mi coche llorando ahí nos
quedamos y de repente abrí una paleta de
manita y de la nada medite serás artista
y como si hubiera sido la señal que
había esperado toda mi vida dije si voy
a hacer y subió una foto a mi instagram
y dije si voy a ser artista y dos
semanas después renuncie a mi trabajo y
le dije a mis papás me voy a dedicar a
pintar y me acuerdo que mi mamá que está
aquí me preguntó geo pero pintar si tú
dijiste que no querías pintar y yo ya sé
les mentí me mentía a mí misma también
si quiero pintar hoy después de cuatro
años les puedo decir que es la mejor
decisión que he tomado en mi vida
y no hablo de pintar hablo de seguir a
mi corazón seguir a mi corazón significa
pintar para mí pero cuestiona te que es
para ti que es seguir a tu corazón para
ti
yo abrí mi instagram
fue lo más valiente que hice decirle al
mundo soy pintora esto es lo que quiero
hacer
y así empezó todo con fotos de mis
cuadros con fotos de cosas que me
gustaban y hoy les puedo decir qué
me siento artista me siento realmente
feliz de lo que he construido me siento
muy orgullosa de la obra de arte que he
estado pintando
la obra maestra de un artista es aquella
por la cual lo reconocemos siempre es la
obra que trasciende el tiempo es aquella
obra que ni siquiera es perfecta
visualmente o ni siquiera es tan
impresionante pero tiene la cualidad de
conectar de inspirar a los demás de que
la recuerdes siempre
esa obra maestra de la que te hablo hoy
es tu vida y entonces hoy te quiero
preguntar que estás pintando te gusta lo
que ves en tu cuadro te gusta lo que hay
ahí
estás poniendo los colores que te gustan
o como yo antes los colores que creí que
le gustaban a los demás
hoy sí te puedo dejar una pregunta es
esa parate de frente a tu obra y piensa
me gusta estoy dispuesta a firmarla con
mi nombre y decir estoy orgulloso
este es el cuadro que yo pinté siendo
pintora es el cuadro que creo que va en
cualquier casa que combina con todo que
complace
este es el cuadro que pinte siendo
artista es el cuadro que a mí me gusta
pintar con los colores que a mí me gusta
con el mensaje que yo quiero dar este es
el cuadro del cual me siento orgulloso
hoy con lo último que te quiero dejar es
con esta frase recuerda que todos
aprendemos siendo pintores pero que
todos fuimos hechos para ser artistas
gracias
[Aplausos]